so it seems like we sort of can't just
have a normal weekend the latest is that
the Des Moines Register canceled the
release of the last Iowa primary poll
before today's caucus in Iowa but in the
poll that did come out Bernie Sanders
has jumped to a 13-point advantage over
Joe Biden with Elizabeth Warren and
second place seven points behind Bernie
so let's take it as I love to do a step
at a time
tonight is the Iowa caucuses these are
the first votes in the 2020 Democratic
primary it is not a primary so instead
of you just you show up at any time
during the day and you vote and then you
leave the way the caucus works is people
gather they talk about the candidates
they try to convince other voters come
over and support my candidate and then
they take an initial vote the viability
threshold in the Iowa caucuses is 15% so
if you take that initial vote and your
candidate is below 15% in any precinct
then you have another round of
discussion and you select another
candidate until everybody remaining has
15% and then the delegates are allocated
proportionally that's the gist of the
way the caucus system works the Des
Moines Register poll is considered the
gold standard Iowa poll and they
announced over the weekend we're not
releasing the poll results because at
least one person who was surveyed said
one of the candidates was not mentioned
when they said of the following
candidates who do you support a
candidate was left out the Des Moines
Register said we don't have evidence
that this happened to more than one
person but we don't have proof that it
didn't and so we are cancelling the
release of the poll and many people
immediately and understandably very
suspicious that this was done either
because Bernie was crushing the results
and they wanted to suppress it or
because Bernie was the one who wasn't
mentioned in the list of candidates we
don't know if that's true but it is
immediately raising suspicions and the
temperature of this entire thing has
just increased dramatically hours before
the caucusing starts tonight now
meanwhile there are other polls we have
a civics DPR or DFP data for progress
poll and
the numbers heavily favored Bernie
Sanders Bernie 28 Warren 21 Biden and
Budaj edge tied at 15 in an average of
recent Iowa polls going into today's
vote the numbers are Bernie leading at
twenty four point seven Biden at
twenty-one Budaj edge at sixteen and
Warren 15 now with these numbers
remember there is proportional
allocation of Delegates with these
percentages you would have Bernie get 10
delegates from Iowa you would have Biden
get 9 Budaj
7 Warren 6 but remember there's a 15%
viability threshold so there's recent
there there's roughly a quarter of the
vote that right now is with candidates
that are below 15% that support will be
reallocated to the other candidates
before the night is over meaning anyone
still could win but the most important
takeaway and I don't want people to
forget this almost anyone can come away
with the most delegates tonight or with
a plurality of the delegates tonight but
no one is going to do better than get
some momentum because there's only 41
delegates tonight so if Bernie gets 9
and Biden gets 10 or Bernie gets 11 and
Biden gets 8 this is almost zero in
context of the entire Democratic primary
that's not to say it doesn't matter
tonight the point is tonight is more
about momentum because getting one more
delegate than the second place person in
terms of the math it doesn't do much in
terms of the headlines in terms of the
PR it does a lot so we will have live
coverage on our YouTube channel on our
twitch channel and on our Facebook page
tonight I hope you'll join we'll be
watching the results coming in will be
taking live calls I will be I think I
actually have a bunch of stuff to give
away also we've got a bunch of stuff
that we've accumulated from different
advertisers and sponsors I mean of stuff
to give away if you live in Iowa go
caucus call into the show afterwards I
will want to hear from you and make sure
you're following me on Twitter at des
Pakman if you experience any
irregularities when you go caucus
tonight in Iowa send me a tweet at D
Pakman I will be monitoring we will take
a quick break
and be back right after this